Netflix's Wednesday leans more into
mystery than the comedy of previous
Adams Family projects but it's still
pretty clever with its references maybe
too clever for its own good viewers who
got this clue probably solved the whole
whodunit spoilers ahead for Wednesday
season one
unsurprisingly given its spooky yet
comedic Source material Wednesday deals
in relatively dark subject matter this
isn't just because of the general
disposition of its titular character but
a body count that quickly grows after
she arrives at her new school Nevermore
Academy somewhere on and around the
premises a killer is lurking he's big
bitey and has eyes on Wednesday who's
bent on bringing to light a conspiracy
that dates back centuries eventually the
smart and sardonic Elder Adams child
uncovers the truth about just who the
man behind this monster happens to be in
hindsight it was a pretty easy case to
crack even with all the red herrings
it's all a part of their nefarious yet
completely obvious plan in particular a
big clue that may have slipped by some
viewers sort of gives the whole game
away you don't need to be a professional
detective or even an amateur High School
sleuth to solve the mystery once you've
noticed it Wednesday eventually reveals
that the creature killing people
wandering in the area of Nevermore
Academy at night is known as a hide the
name is a clever reference to the
horrific other half of the dear old Dr
Jekyll from Robert Louis Stevenson's
book Strange Case of Dr Jekyll and Mr
Hyde even if you haven't read the book
you're probably aware of it through its
many adaptations parodies and homages
Stevenson's Novella Stars a
mild-mannered doctor named Jekyll Who
develops a murderous Alter Ego in an
experiment gone wrong so when it turns
out that the killer on Wednesday goes by
hide then it's pretty evident that his
secret identity wouldn't be someone with
an outwardly violent disposition they'd
be kind by all appearances keeping their
murderous intense suppressed and hidden
with all this in mind one of Wednesday's
classmates at the Nevermore Academy
quick becomes suspect number one in the
search for its serial killer as the
saying goes it really is always the
quiet ones lots of the students at
Nevermore are just as gloomy or strange
as Wednesday but one of the few normies
Wednesday becomes attached to is Tyler
Galpin the chatty Barista who becomes
smitten with the gothic schoolgirl Tyler
is sweet caring and seems the sort that
wouldn't hurt a fly a real Jekyll type
you might say with that in mind of
course he's hiding a beastly secret in
the form of a seven foot tall feral
creature he can't contain the big
difference between Tyler and the good
doctor from Stevenson's book is that
Tyler doesn't create his vicious Alter
Ego in an experiment he carries his
curse thanks to his family heritage even
so this split between man and monster
still lines up with its inspiration the
dead giveaway nature of the creature's
name likely explains why Wednesday
doesn't uncover what it's called until
pretty late in the series when she even
notes its literary origin it's called a
hide
isn't Jekyll and Hyde unfortunately the
damage Tyler and flicks leaves its mark
his mild Maynard side is eventually
subsumed by his horrific nature and he
becomes like the creature even in his
human form if Wednesday gets a second
season you might expect the love that
could have been for our heroine manifest
as an unhinged enemy who comes back for
Revenge honestly High School romances
really are nothing but trouble